attentat à la bombe au bhv rivoli un
mort six blessés
quelques incidents à paris à l'arrivée
des marcheurs du larzac
youssef keith moon est sorti de prison
la procédure de révision de son procès
et déclencher le romantisme pas mort
mais quels sont les vrais remonter
bonsoir attentats au bhv au bazar de
l'hôtel de ville en début d'après midi à
paris il y a eu six morts un blessé six
blessés plus tôt dont un dans un état
très grave
le préfet de police monsieur sommes vus
il s'est rendu immédiatement sur les
lieux
lorsqu'on apprend qu'un attentat s'est
produit dans un grand magasin un samedi
en cette période de l'année on pense au
pire bien sur le fait que l'engin
explosif était placé au sous sol dans un
endroit où il ya plus de passage a
réduit tout de même les conséquences de
cet attentat
l'explosion a eu lieu dans un
renfoncement de rayons quincaillerie
située au premier sous-sol du magasin
heureusement moins fréquenté que les
étages car on estime en effet à plus de
5000 personnes le nombre de clients à
cette heure-là
les experts du laboratoire central de la
préfecture de police ont aussitôt tenté
de déterminer l'origine de cette
explosion qui n'est toujours pas
revendiqué ce n'est pas la première fois
que le bhv est ainsi visé en juin
dernier une bombe avait été découverte
au rayon jouets par une employée qui
avait pu alerter à temps les services de
sécurité youssef keith moon est sorti de
prison
youssef keith moon c'est ce jeune
algérien de 27 ans qui avait été
condamné à 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle pour un meurtre dont il a
toujours nié être l'auteur
par une décision exceptionnelle il vient
d'obtenir un complément d'enquêté et une
suspension provisoire de sa peine
la commission de révision des procès
criminels et correctionnel veut en effet
obtenir des renseignements
complémentaires sur cette affaire car à
aucun moment on répète les avocats on a
trouvé un indice une une empreinte une
preuve susceptible d'un cap les yosef
kismoune rien simplement une
dénonciation
un couple de commerçants l'accusent en
effet du meurtre de madame b car une
commerçante de 73 ans découverte
assassinée le 26 mai 1975 à creil dans
l'oise
cinq mois plus tard youssef keith moon
un ouvrier algérien est arrêté puis
inculpé de meurtre deux ans après il est
condamné par la cour d'assises de l'oise
à 20 ans de réclusion criminelle en
prison kismoune crie son innocence et le
6 octobre dernier
il entame une grève de la faim tandis
que son avocat engage une procédure de
révision du procès admis d'urgence à
l'hôtel dieu
keith moon en est donc ressorti cet
après midi plus de trois ans après son
arrestation
j'avais des moments de désespoir et et
d'impuissance
d'autant plus que qu'à ses débuts je
n'avais pas l'assistance d'un mètre
libye vous avez toujours cru à votre
libération
depuis le jour où m imeem a juré qu'elle
ferait son possible pour me sortir et
j'aurai une grande foi en elle vit et
crus l'e coli toujours c'est toujours
pas de désespoir par moments le cid et
désespoir mais fuit toujours mon côté
pour me me remonter bombe ont eu une
part de ce désespoir
est-ce que lorsque vous avez repenser au
jugement au procès est ce que vous avez
senti qu'il y avait aussi une cabale
raciste dans ce procès
anton étrangers je ne prendrai pas de
mots si roddick au 10 ans mais il est
heureux qui qui certains fléaux sociaux
et qui sont sur tènement commun à
beaucoup de pays à tous peut-être faire
tellement et il faut lutter entre se
vende de fléau qu'est ce que vous allez
faire maintenant vous êtes libre je suis
libre en verrine pds qui va falloir
réapprendre
la liberté je ne pense pas je me suis
toujours adapté très vite aux situations
comme à mon arrivée en france d'ailleurs
me suis très vite adopté à lors de mon
emprisonnement fait très vite su faire
abstraction de certains problèmes de
promiscuité et autres je ne pense pas
que j'aurai beaucoup de problèmes aux
arrêts à prendre et ça me réinsérer non
lof sociaux duceppe keith moon sorti de
prison mais pas vraiment libre paul
lefèvre que va-t-il se passer maintenant
mais il faut rappeler que cette
commission de révision des procès
criminels est composé de trois
conseillers à la cour de cassation et
trois directeurs de la chancellerie aux
magistrats sa demande de complément dans
le iv qui a porté en grande partie sur
un nouvel examen des rapports d'autopsié
la victime ne veut pas dire forcément qu
il y aura révision du procès mais le
fait que le garde des sceaux est déjà
décidée sans y être obligé d'ailleurs de
suspendre l'accomplissement de la peine
signifie que les observations de m
gisèle halimi l'avocat de kiss rhône ont
provoqué une réflexion de doute dans
l'esprit des six aux magistrats et ça
n'est pas rien
lorsque la commission aura le rapport
définitif elle émettra un avis en
fonction de cet avis le garde des sceaux
aura la possibilité soit de racheter la
demande en révision donc et servait
intégré qui se mène en prison soit de
saisir la cour de cassation qui à son
tour examinera les éléments nouveaux et
si kousmine est acquittée par une autre
cour d'assises et bien il faudra essayer
de retrouver le meurtrier d'une vieille
dame de 73 ans est tout fait il ya trois
ans chez elle non qu est d'autant plus
difficile que les premières recherches
contesté avant d'être éventuellement
contestable on peut être déjà effacé les
traces mais voyez vous dans cette
affaire il ya au moins un aspect positif
celui de démontrer que le système
judiciaire français n'est pas tout à
fait complètement bloquée
la dernière étape de la marche du larzac
les manifestants sont arrivés à paris ou
plutôt dans la banlieue parisienne cet
après midi puisque le défilé n'était
autorisée que de la porte d'orléans à la
porte d'italie
les paysans du larzac avec leur famille
une centaine de personnes précédait le
cortège composé de plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de manifestants dans la soirée
il ya eu quelques incidents entre des
autonomes et les forces de police qui
encadraient la manifestation jean
jacques dufour les paysans du larzac
arrive porte d'orléans au terme d'une
marge de 710 km ils sont accueillis par
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
manifestants répondant à l'appel des
comités larzac d'organisations
politiques syndicales agricoles
antimilitariste et c'est la marche
pacifique et silencieuse débute aussitôt
et le cortège sous un froid ville prend
la direction de la porte d'italie en
tête de la manifestation les paysans et
leurs familles sont une centaine environ
précédés d'une grande banderole sur
laquelle on peut lire nous gardons le
large
c'est peu après 15h que des incidents
éclatent à la hauteur du parc montsouris
une centaine de jeunes gens venus là
pour en découdre et pas pour autre chose
lance des projectiles divers sur les
policiers provoquant des heurts
sporadiques se poursuivent presque
jusqu'à la porte d'italie
pendant que derrière la manifestation
proprement dits se déroule dans le calme
peu avant la dispersion du cortège les
paysans du larzac tiennent un bref
meeting pour rappeler qu'ils sont venus
à paris afin de demander au président de
la république de mettre fin à
l'extension du port militaire sur le
plateau une extension que le paysan
recul depuis maintenant 8
le 30 octobre 1970 michel debré alors
ministre des armées décide extension de
ce camp créé en 1902 son emprise doit
être portée de 3000 à 17 milles hectares
soit deux mille fois la place de la
concorde
la majorité des élus et des
organisations professionnelles qui n'ont
pas été consultés préalablement s'oppose
à cette décision
cette extension touche 11 communes et
elle concerne à des degrés divers
71 exploitations agricoles dont une
vingtaine selon l'armée seront rayés de
la carte
mais pour les paysans ces cinquante à
soixante fermes qui sont menacés
directement de disparition et cet
agrandissement distille va assécher les
deux mamelles de la région le tourisme
et le roquefort pour eux cette
amputation de 14 mille hectares de
pacage entraînera la perte de 1 million
300 mille litres de lait de prob y soit
325 tonnes de fromage qui correspond à
la moitié de nos exportations vers les
usa pour l'armée la collecte sur le
causse ne baissera que de 325 mille
litres soit l'équivalent de 90 tonnes de
roquefort
sur les 103 paysans qui ont fait le
serment de garder leurs terres ils sont
passés depuis à l'ennemi mais cette
défection a été compensée par
l'installation de huit nouveaux
agriculteurs sur le larzac et la petite
guerre de position que se livrent les
paysans et les militaires fait songer à
une gigantesque partie de da l'armée
encercle certes les bastions de
résistance avec ses 6000 hectares acquis
à l'amiable mais les paysans grâce au
groupement foncier agricole sont
parvenus à lui souffler plus d'un
millier d'hectares des terrains
stratégiques qui sont autant de verrous
bloquant la progression militaire la
situation semblait donc figé qu'en fin
octobre
l'armée tentait une percée avec une arme
nouvelle la signature d ordonnance
d'expropriation des terrains situés sur
les communes de la cavalerie et de rock
sainte marie
l'armée encore non pas à propos du
larzac mais à propos de son moral est
bien l'état d'esprit qui règne
aujourd'hui dans l'armée française est
bien meilleur qu'en 75 c'est le général
billard qui parle ainsi dans une
interview recueillie par l' afp le
commandant de la 1re armée qui compte
cent vingt mille hommes s'insurge contre
ceux qui continuent à dire que l'armée
et l'école de la paresse depuis trois
ans nous avons fait d'énormes progrès
dans cette interview le général billard
souligner l'excellente cote d'amour dont
jouissent les militaires français auprès
de leurs partenaires notamment après les
opérations de kolwezi au zaïre la
situation en iran nouvelle manifestation
aujourd'hui à téhéran et nouvelle
fusillade
il y aurait eu 20 morts encore ajouté au
bilan d'hier sept morts selon les
autorités plus de quarante cinq victimes
et 3 195 blessés selon l'opposition
observant les consignes du gouvernement
militaire l'armée a tiré contre les
manifestants et téhéran est replongé
depuis 24 heures dans de nouveaux
troubles religieux à l'origine de ces
manifestations en effet le début de la
période de 10 jours pendant laquelle les
musulmans chiites observent le deuil de
moharram c'est le 2e et du mois de
moharram qui commémore l'assassinât du
petit fils de mahomet donc l'imam chiite
pas le califat omeyyade ça commençait
hier samedi ça dure tout le mois de
muharram dont 28 jours et le sommet
c'est le 10 décembre le jeu le jour de
l'assassinât de l'imam et comment
expliquer que ce fanatisme religieux se
transforment systématiquement en
manifestation politique contre le champ
parce que le schisme est une
manifestation politique contre
l'occupant arabe
d'abord c'est pourquoi le schisme a été
créée contre le cynisme de l'islam arabe
ensuite quand le califat ottomane c'est
à ça que l'iran doit son indépendance et
enfin la religion contrairement aux
autres pays du monde a toujours été
séparé du pouvoir en iran a toujours été
un anti pouvoir en iran dont les ulémas
chiites ont plus ou moins été compte les
souffrances en place alors d'un côté il
ya le shah d'iran
notre côté il ya la population qu'est ce
qui peut faire aujourd'hui le chat je
crois que le ch a un calendrier entre
lapointe d'abord par son gouvernement
militaire ni civile essayé et de baisser
la tension
essayez d'en terminer avec les grèves
premiers points 2e point essayez est de
mettre sur place un gouvernement d'union
nationale avec naturellement le front
national 12 octobre au sein d'aig
les quelques partis de droite ou de
gauche mais toujours centriste et si
possible avec certains leaders religieux
modérés troisième point et essayer de se
retirer de la scène au profit de son
fils dès que le fils aura valdes ans à
dire dans un an et demi en algérie pour
la première fois un journal fait
allusion ce matin à l'après boumédiène
ceux qui croient que l'algérie d'après
vous médiane changera totalement de
visage écrit le quotidien à chappes ce
matin et bien se trompe dans leurs
prévisions
l'un des mérites de notre peuple et
d'être fidèle à ses principes le
militant houari boumédiène on a été le
symbole je vous rappelle que le
président algérien est toujours dans un
coma dépassé et en réanimation total
depuis mercredi un bulletin de santé
publié ce soir par le pourtant d'un état
de santé qui est reversi bhl le nouveau
ministre français des affaires
étrangères monsieur jean françois poncet
a adressé aujourd'hui un message à son
homologue algérien monsieur bouteflika
pour former des voeux pour la santé du
président boumediene et pour assurer que
l'une de ses premières tâches et la tête
de la diplomatie française sera de
resserrer les liens de coopération dans
tous les domaines entre paris et alger
je n'irai pas à oslo pour recevoir le
prix nobel de la paix a expliqué le
président sadate car le traité de paix
entre l'egypte et israël ne pourra pas
être signé dans l'avenir immédiat
c'est le conseiller politique du
président égyptien qui recevra le prix à
sa place tant que la paix n'aura pas été
conclu ce serait ridicule que le
président sadate prennent place à côté
de monsieur béguines pendant les
cérémonies d'oslo c'est un diplomate
égyptien qu'il a expliqué aujourd'hui
nouvelle tragédie pour les réfugiés
vietnamiens qui quittent le pays essaie
d'aborder les côtes malaisiennes
un bateau transportant 300 personnes
vient de couler il y aurait 43 morts et
84 disparus
il a été rejeté au large par les
policiers et puis le bateau a été
submergé
et disloqué par les vagues 43 et puis
dans le journal le monde ce soir comme
d'ailleurs dans une trentaine de
journaux d'amérique d'asie et d'europe
deux pages en espagnol signé farne f arn
ce sont les forces armées de résistance
nationale une organisation clandestine
d'extrême gauche qui a enlevé le 24
novembre dernier le directeur de la
filiale phillips au salvador
cette double page publiée aujourd'hui
dans le monde et simultanément dans une
trentaine de journaux d'amérique et
d'europe est le fruit de négociations
entre la direction de la firme philips
en hollande est une organisation
clandestine de gauche
le phare pour la libération du président
de la firme au salvador
monsieur fritzsch whitman âgé de 34 ans
le voici cet enlèvement le quatrième en
quelques mois et le signe de la tension
politique qui règne actuellement au
salvador
ce petit pays d'amérique centrale de 4
millions d'habitants très peuplées qui
vit sous la dictature du général carlos
romero 14e prend de grandes familles se
partagent le pays une population pauvre
rançonnés par la phalange groupe para
militaires de luttre contre de lutte
contre le communisme qui entretiennent
un climat de violence et de répression
quelque part en amérique centrale j'ai
rencontré il ya quelques semaines
responsable plus phare pour kellerman
cienfuegos dont la signature est évident
le monde et ils me disaient leur colère
parce que dit-il et il était les
conditions quasi sinon elle est
persécutée autorise à la cara pour les
stylos des persécutions
et persécution leur dernière trouvaille
c'est de prendre un homme de le ligoter
de lui mettre le visage dans une cagoule
et puis j'en ai lui a caché de la viande
fraîche sur le corps et il lâche déchets
a fermé une torture psychologique c'est
contre cela que nous nous battons contre
cela que nous voulons attirer
l'attention dossier social maintenant en
france grève des dockers cgt de
marseille aujourd'hui elle a été suivie
à 100%
et puis suite de la grève des agents de
conduite de la gare de lyon à paris avec
toujours des perturbations sur les
lignes de banlieue
le trafic sur les grandes lignes est
normal un sondage sofres publié par le
nouvel observateur réalisé entre le 27
octobre et le 2 novembre
un tiers des français seulement crois
qu'un gouvernement de gauche pourrait
réduire le chômage
et puis 72 % des jeunes estiment qu'un
jour il pourrait leur arriver d'être
chômeur un mauvais coup dirigé par le
marché commun dirigé contre le marché
commun agricole et par conséquent contre
l'agriculture française c'est le
jugement de jean lecanuet le président
de l'udf à propos du vote de l'assemblée
nationale refusant l'harmonisation de la
tva au sein du marché commun
réponse cet après midi pour le rpr par
la voix de bernard pons députée de
l'essonne ce vote ne porte pas atteinte
à l'intérêt des agriculteurs français
mais défend au contraire les
prérogatives du parlement français les
jeunes rpr réunis à paris pour une
convention extraordinaire jacques chirac
toujours hospitalisée n'a pas pu
assister à la réunion mais il a fait
lire un message à la tribune un message
dans lequel il dit notamment jaune vous
refusez les concessions les abandons les
renoncements vous déranger comme je vous
comprends
daniel brahim qui a suivi pour nous
cette convention des jeunes rpr a été
surprise elle par l'atmosphère des
débats une atmosphère de contestation
qui englobait tout à la fois le chef de
l'état lé paris
même les députés rhdp à travers les
discours on retrouvait sur l'europe des
tests de michel debré sur l'économie
celle de chirac et sur le centriste
celle d'alexandre sanguinetti
de tous temps des deux oppositions des
missions et chirac président aux élus du
rpr ces jeunes sans mandat clament leur
mépris des valses hésitations et tout en
se proclamant défenseurs des
institutions
ils n'hésitent pas à considérer que si
l'on volonté nous sommes qu'on sera
mieux beau ouvrir une crise de riches
peu importe que nous soyons ou non dans
la majorité
komlosy accepte qu'on mesure refuse
cette majorité ne nous intéresse pas
elle appartient au parti
elle appartient au passé comme
lappartient d'ailleurs ce gouvernement
couleurs de murailles qu'à la prétention
s'identifiait l'an 2000 quelle
prétention mon dieu ce qui nous
intéresse et dénis jacques chine à
assumer pleinement le destin qui est le
sien et qui est grand tellement grand
sur votre agenda
les jours à venir notait bien le début à
paris la semaine prochaine de la
première semaine de la jeunesse une
exposition où les jeunes pourront se
renseigner sur les métiers les loisirs
et le sport à la fin de la semaine
prochaine le 9 décembre elle se
terminera cette semaine de la jeunesse
par un discours de valéry giscard
d'estaing demain dans notre journal de
13 heures 15 la lettre ouverte à l'an
2000 sera consacré à une interview de
michel poniatowski a réalisé par georges
leclercq à propos du livre de l'ancien
ministre l'avenir n'est écrit nulle part
et puis - politique mais sur votre
agenda tout de même sur votre agenda de
télévision noté le rendez vous que vous
fixe demain soir antenne 2 en direct du
palais garnier nous retransmettrons
simon boccanegra un opéra de verdi que
le public français vient de découvrir
dans une mise en scène de giorgio
strehler depuis sous la baguette de
claudio abbado le rôle de simon
boccanegra est tenu par pierrot capucci
lit un baryton à la voix exceptionnelle
que patrick lecocq et georges bbu ont
rencontré pour nous
ses vocalises sur fond d'aéroports sont
celles de pierrot kaput chili un des
tout premiers baryton au monde et
titulaires des plus grands rôles à la
scala de milan
kaputt chili est un passionné de vitesse
et depuis qu'on lui a interdit de
piloter
il fait de longues promenades
nostalgique sur les pistes quant à sa
voix il la travaille l'entretien chaque
jour mais il ne veut pas en être
l'esclave non plus que l'esclave des
grandes partitions et il lui arrive
souvent de prêter sa voix à la canso net
la loire doit être à mon service
pas moi même au service de la
non
deux jours
m
ouf
sinon vous reconnaitre c'est une
opération difficile c'est pas l'opéra
seulement vocale mais mais artistique et
alors il faut avoir beaucoup de beaucoup
d'années sur le carré pour faire ça
c'est tout une question de de travail
vraiment il ya plusieurs collègues
qu'elle chante cet opéra un doigt entre
trois années de carrière mais c'est pas
un c'est pas bien comme ça et là bois
fini complètement parce qu'ils sont des
opéras très dramatique et provinces
périence une expérience vocale
expérience de scène artistique
oh et
beau
à
m
c
voilà vos cannes et grasse immonde
demain soir sur antenne 2 puis je vous
rappelle que cet opéra sera retransmis
simultanément en stéréophonie par france
musique de l'opéra au romantisme
il n'y a qu'un pas qu'un soupir plutôt
que je franchi aisément pour vous parler
maintenant de ce regain allez je vais
employer le mot de cette mode du
romantisme
à tel point qu'une académie romantique
vient d'être créé les principaux membres
en sont gonzague saint bris écrivain et
confident radiophonique brice lalonde
écologiste militant francis huster
comédiens les patrick poivre d'arvor que
je ne vous ferai pas l'injure de
présenter à l'époque la saison et dans
l'automne les feuilles mortes
hervé claude a pris un grand foulard une
large caps et sans étaler de par les
rues s'enquérir de ce nouveau romantisme
et au hasard de ses rencontres il a posé
la question qu'est ce que le romantisme
je prends pour a laissé aller
nostalgique
moi je me sentais du tour saint jacques
et le laisser-aller chou parents ont
disparu
aux endroits
et plus belle
d'autres j'ai l'impression qu'en 78 des
chansons romantiques pas socialement ou
enfin
exemple sont à s'accrocher à la vie de
tous les jours à ces matériels et puis
c'est tout ils prennent pas le temps
revendiquons ce soir
même si joe si ce dernier
vesna en corner
à leur manière
qui s est que les romantiques s'est
plutôt tourné vers la mort etc
je n'ai pas choisi l'amour
et
les filles s'en défendent les garçons le
regrette mais tous y pensent l'air est
au romantisme une meute schubert par ci
un regain de passion dans la littérature
par là après les nouveaux philosophes
voici les nouveaux romantiques jeune
ambitieux il aime faire parler d'eux et
puis le romantisme peut rassembler sous
sa bannière presque tout et son
contraire de l'écologie au punk en
passant par les rapports sexuels ou le
régionalisme le tout est d'y mettre un
peu de passion ce monde d'aujourd'hui
n'a pas l'air romantique il a l'air dur
mais c'est contre lui que le romantisme
existe et c'est pour le transformer et
pour le rendre heureux
tout à l'heure on a rencontré une jeune
fille qui parlait de la défense ici où
elle habite
elle a dit oui si ça a pas l'air très
gaie comme ça mais le week end
tous les gens qui habitent la défense se
retrouve comme dans un village et ils
s'embrassent près des jets d'eau mais
les romantiques départ c'était quand
même des gens brument ça voulait c'était
des gens contestataires des gens
complètement révolte contre leur société
vous vous êtes fait romantique moderne
où des gens se faire intégrer je crois
pas je crois que le mouvement
insurrectionnel du romantisme
c'est n'est pas une révolte de brutalité
de violence on a assez de brutalité et
de violence
c'est une révolte beaucoup plus forte
c'est la révolte de l'amour de leurs
glorieux aînés qui s'appelle musset
lamartine hugo qu'ils envient les
mouvements de cap les batailles dernier
les extravagances mais le romantisme
c'était d'abord un mouvement de
libération une réaction contre une vie
trop rationnel une pensée trop classique
c'était un mouvement plein de folie et
d'orages à l'image des toiles de gerry
les nouveaux romantiques trop bien
installée dans la vie moderne n'en ont
peut-être pris que l'affectation
l'autre jour j'ai assisté un déjeuner
avec des jeunes femmes ravissante et
puis n'employer que des mots romantique
elle disait des mots ânesse vous savez
avec des dents serrées et passionnément
fascinant 1,10 et patients passionné
passionnément et et tenez par exemple
vous vous rappelez la chanson déviera
tenu ce de victor hugo
si tu veux faisons un rêve mon temps sur
deux pôles froid je t'enlève tu
m'emmènes l'oiseau chante au fond des
bois mais aujourd'hui les jeunes font
cela aussi mais il monte à 2 sur le même
pas le froid qui est la moto la honte
d'azuki avec la petite mignonne derrière
qui sert 100 millions par devant
attitude romantique et de même c'est
façon non plus donner le bras et de s'en
lasser les bras croisés par derrière
c'est une attitude profondément
romantique et pourquoi est ce que la
période actuelle se prête plus au
romantisme mais justement par réaction
réaction contre les organigrammes contre
les ordinateurs quand tous les
idéologies réaction de spontanéité
réaction de passion et de liberté folle
vitesse que vous même vous sentez un
personnage vraiment beaucoup avec les
cheveux à l'intérieur
la moto romantique pourquoi pas en tout
cas les marchands ne s'y trompe pas
qu'il soit une passade ou une aspiration
réel des jeunes le romantisme fait
vendre la mode la publicité récupèrent à
leur tour pourtant cela n'empêche pas
les sentiments sincères la génération de
68 celle qui a laissé beaucoup
d'illusions à paris comme à prague
cette génération là est sans doute
sincèrement romantique mais elle l'est
avec pudeur avoir le courage de rêver le
matin le jour dans la rue
enfin laisser une grande place à
l'imagination qu'au cours de la journée
sa vie 21 sa vie la réalité d'un peu de
rennes
et pour servir la vérité romantique
c'était gonzague saint bris qui avait
les sharks étaient pas hervé claude me
reste à vous parler de la météo pour
demain
et bien comme aujourd'hui lire encore de
la neige vous le voyez aujourd'hui il ya
eu de la neige en normandie belliot
magna va encore en particulier sur les
algues et la vallée du rhône
il y aura un temps froid et brumeux qui
va persister sur les flandres toute la
journée sur la picardie l'alsace la
lorraine la bourgogne
il y aura une perturbation également
qu'il a abordés dans la matinée les
côtes de l'atlantique donnant des pluies
atteignant dans la soirée la normandie
le centre et le massif central des vents
assez forts sont à craindre sur la
manche et l'atlantique
vous avez rendez vous avec pierre-alain
à 23h37 pour la dernière édition du
journal avec comme chaque samedi la
rubrique cinéma de france roche je
retrouverai pour ma part avec grand
plaisir à 13h15 demain pour une édition
de la mi journée du journal d'antenne 2
souhaite une très belle soirée sur
antenne 2